Is everyone here?
Gather around.
I'm sure you already know,
but a horrible incident happened
at school this morning.
Tem, the actor...
President!
This is the only place
Tem was in contact with the carnivores.
And?
Are you suspecting us?
Maybe someone got jealous of him
for getting a good role.
How dare you say that!
Herbivores are always like this.
Wanna start a fight?
-I can't open these walnuts.
-If a carnivore hurts a herbivore...
-Where's Legoshi?
-...they would be expelled.
-Hey.
-Ridiculous!
-Legoshi isn't a nutcracker.
-You're not even worth using my fangs.
-Stop it!
-You're right.
-You're both stripes.
-Legoshi isn't here.
Where has he gone?
I'm scared.
Those were eyes looking at prey.
That wolf's telling me that I'm next.
You're overthinking.
Legoshi's always been a bit weird.
You can come see me anytime.
We prosimians are always fun and cheerful.
Thank you.
Good night.
Stay away.
You pretend to be our friend,
but once you're hungry, we're your food?
Don't look down on us!
Tem and I are much more...
Here.
It's a love letter. For you.
I waited so we could be alone.